>>> IN OUR NATIONAL LEAD TODAY,
WE ARE LEARNING THAT TWO SENATE
COMMITTEES ARE SET TO RELEASE
NEW REPORTS ON THE MULTIPLE
SECURITY FAILURES SURROUNDING
THE JANUARY 6th RAMPAGE.
THEY'RE LEAVING OUT TRUMP'S ROLE
IN INCITING THAT RIOT.
LACK OF ANSWERS THAT INCLUDED
WHITEWASHING OF BRUTALITY IS
INSULTING TO MANY WHO DEFENDED
THE NATION'S CAPITOL THAT DAY,
INCLUDING TWO FORS WHO SPOKE
WITH CNN IN AN EXCLUSIVE SITDOWN
THAT THEY THOUGHT THEY WOULDN'T
SK
ESCAPE ALIVE AND HEARD FIRSTHAND
THE ATTACKERS SAYING TRUMP SENT
US.
WHITNEY WILD SAT DOWN WITH THOSE
CAPITOL POLICE OFFICERS WHO
SHARED FOR THE FIRST TIME VIVID
DETAILS OF ONE OF THE COUNTRY'S
DARKEST DAYS.
>> Reporter: WHAT WAS THE WORSE
THING THEY CALLED YOU?
>> TRAITOR.
>> WHY WAS THAT THE WORSE THING?
>> BECAUSE I SERVE MY COUNTRY.
I WENT OVERSEAS TO PROTECT OUR
HOMELAND FROM FOREIGN THREATS.
YET HERE I AM, BATTLING THEM IN
OUR OWN CAPITOL.
>> Reporter: UNITED STATES
CAPITOL POLICE SERGEANT AQUILINO
GONELL, DEPLOYED TO IRAQ IN 2003
AND THEN JOINED CAPITOL POLICE
IN 2008.
HE IS SPEAKING PUBLICLY FOR THE
FIRST TIME ABOUT JANUARY 6th
WHEN HE FOUGHT RIOTERS TRYING TO
STOP THE CERTIFICATION OF JOE
BIDEN'S PRESIDENCY.
>> I GOT HURT.
I GOT HURT.
I WOULD DO IT AGAIN IF I HAD TO.
IT'S MY JOB.
>> YOU TRAITOR.
>> Reporter: SERGEANT GONELL LED
MEMBERS OF THE CIVIL DISTURBANCE
UNIT.
THIS VIDEO SHOWS HIS FIGHT ON
THE WEST FRONT.
>> THEY KEPT SAYING TRUMP SENT
ME.
WE WON'T LISTEN TO YOU.
WE ARE HERE TO TAKE OVER THE
CAPITOL.
WE ARE HERE TO HANG MIKE PENCE.
THEY THOUGHT WE WERE THERE FOR
THAT AND WE WERE SO THEY TURNED
AGAINST US.
IT'S VERY SCARY BECAUSE I
THOUGHT I WAS GOING TO LOSE MY
LIFE RIGHT THERE.
>> Reporter: SOME OF THE MOST
HORRIFIC VIDEO SHOWS SERGEANT
GONELL STEPS FROM METROPOLITAN
POLICE OFFICER DANIEL HODGES
CAUGHT IN A DOORWAY.
>> I COULD HEAR MY FELLOW
OFFICER SCREAMING.
ALL I COULD THINK WAS WE CAN'T
LET THESE PEOPLE IN.
THERE'S GOING TO BE A SLAUGHTER
INSIDE.
>> Reporter: RIOTERS BEAT
SERGEANT GONELL SO BADLY THEY
CUT HIS HAND AND HE NEEDED FOOT
SURGERY.
WHILE HE FENDED OFF THE ATTACK
OUTSIDE, OFFICER EVANS LOCKED
DOWN AREAS INSIDE THE CAPITOL
AND SEE VAC WAITED SENATORS.
DID YOU EVER THINK THIS MIGHT BE
A LIFE OR DEATH SITUATION FOR
YOU?
>> I REMEMBER SPECIFICALLY
THINKING IT WHEN I WAS ON THE
FLOOR.
I REMEMBER THINKING STUFF LIKE,
THIS IS THE DAY.
ALL THOSE TIMES YOU HAVE GIVEN
THOUGHT ON WHAT YOU WOULD DO,
YOU'RE DOING IT.
>> Reporter: FOUR HOURS, EVANS
AND THE SENATORS WATCHED THE
RIOT ON TV FROM A SECURED
LOCATION.
>> I REMEMBER THE ANGER I FELT
WHEN I SAW THOSE IMAGES, BUSTING
WINDOWS, CLIMBING THE WALLS AND
STUFF LIKE THAT.
IT WAS AN AUDIBLE GASP IN THE
ROOM.
>> Reporter: AROUND 6:00, THE
RIOT HAD CALMED ENOUGH THAT
SERGEANT GONELL COULD FINALLY
TELL HIS WIFE HE HAD IS SURVIVE
>> I STARTED TEXTING MY WIFE.
AND WHAT I SAID TO HER, I'M
OKAY.
SEE YOU WHENEVER.
>> Reporter: CONGRESS RESUMED
CERTIFYING THE ELECTORAL COLLEGE
VOTES AND THAT NIGHT SERGEANT
GONELL ARRIVED BACK HOME 3:00
A.M. JANUARY 7th BUT FOUND
LITTLE RELIEF.
>> WHEN I CAME IN, SHE WANTED TO
HUG ME AND I TOLD HER NO BECAUSE
I WAS COVER ED -- I WAS COVERED
IN PEPPER SPRAY.
MY HANDS WERE BLEEDING STILL.
AND I COULDN'T EVEN SLEEP
BECAUSE I WENT TO TAKE A SHOWER.
AND INSTEAD OF HELPING THAT
REINFLAMED THE CHEMICALS.
>> Reporter: IT HAD SOAK ED
THROUGH YOUR CLOTHES?
>> YES.
TOOK A BATH OF MILK.
>> Reporter: HOURS LATER HE,
OFFICER EVANS AND HUNDREDS MORE
OFFICERS STILL REELING FROM THE
WORST ATTACK IN TWO CENTURIES
HEADED BACK TO WORK.
>> I DID GIVE MY WIFE A HUG AND
STARTED CRYING.
>> Reporter: WHY?
>> EVERYTHING THAT HAPPENED.
I THOUGHT I WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO
SEE THEM.
I WENT TO MY SON'S BED AND GAVE
HIM A HUG.
HE WAS ASLEEP STILL.
GAVE HIM A BIG KISS, AND STARTED
CRYING.
IT WAS LIKE FIVE, TEN MINUTES
HUG.
I JUST CRIED.
KEPT TELLING ME IT'S GOING TO BE
OKAY AND I WAS LIKE, NO, I'VE
GOT TO GO BACK TO WORK.
I'VE GOT TO GO BACK TO WORK.
>> Reporter: FOR HIM THE RIOT IS
HARDLY IN THE REAR VIEW.
>> THE MOTION IS NOT AGREED TO.
>> Reporter: FAILURE TO PASS A
BILL TO INVESTIGATE THE CAUSES
OF THE INVESTIGATION GAVE HIM
REASON TO SPEAK OUT.
>> IT HURTS ME THAT THE COUNTRY
THAT I LOVE, THAT I CAME IN,
THAT I SACRIFICED SO MUCH DON'T
CARE ABOUT US.
THEY DON'T.
>> Reporter: THE DAY THE BILL
WAS VOTED DOWN, SERGEANT GONELL
CAME FORWARD ON HIS OWN, NOT ON
BEHALF OF THE DEPARTMENT,
TELLING US HE COULD NO LONGER
STAY SILENT.
JAKE?
>> POWER FUL, POW